in march the uk repaid a long-standing
debt to tehran paving the way for the
release of nazanin zagari ratcliffe and
anushay ashori from prison in iran but
the plain home had a passenger missing
the environmentalist morad tabes his
family say a pledge to bring morad back
to the uk was broken by the foreign
office now they say they feel abandoned
i've been speaking to roxanne tabas
morad's daughter she's not just fighting
for his release but also her mother
who's been banned from traveling out of
tehran during our interview she told me
about the toll the ordeal's taken on her
family and her fears for her father
roxanne fuzzy thanks for coming on the
show and spending some time with us i
want to talk to you about your dad morad
tabes who is still imprisoned in iran
can you tell us about your
father's situation he's still in even
in the prison he was meant to be on a
furlough which we still haven't seen
come to fruition and it's been now five
weeks since the others returned so i
think he's feeling quite abandoned and
and a little bit hopeless i think so
there was a deal and you hoped your dad
murad would come home with nazanin's
kyrie radcliffe and anushay shuri who
are both now back in the uk but your dad
has ended up back
in evan prison where they were both
incarcerated as well how did he end up
in this situation he was in iran for his
wildlife conservation efforts um
and he he got picked up in january 2018
um
but i think it it came as a huge shock
and surprise to all of us because
i mean he was there to to help really
um
and it was it was definitely something i
think hit all of us quite hard we felt
that there must have been a mistake or
the
messaging wasn't right but it it was
really
difficult to stomach um
and it's been ongoing so it's been over
four years now and how did you discover
your dad had been arrested
we got a call from from a family member
um to say that they just heard
that he'd been taken and
and my mum was put on a travel ban and
she's still there as well so your dad
was in iran was arrested your mum was
there with him and is now in a travel
ban and your dad has been in the same
prison that nazanina and nushay were in
and he's been there since 2018 or 2019.
how does your dad sustain
himself in there keep himself sane
do you get to talk to him
he's always been a very positive person
so i think he
tries to look for any sort of light if
you will that he can
um
but
but yeah i think anybody in those
circumstances will will struggle to
to have hope really
um
it's
it's a difficult one because
any time we've communicated to him it's
been through my mom and she'll put two
phones on speaker next to each other and
we kind of shout across
but my dad's
the ultimate dad so he never lets on
that he's having a bad day or that he's
not feeling well he's always
asking about his children and how we are
and if there's any news that we want to
share with him and
and just to share i love ease and i
misuse and we're here for each other
really but he's not very well is he your
dad no
he had cancer
some time ago and had quite a lot of
health complications coming out of it
and a lot of those still require ongoing
treatment and monitoring so so we do
worry for him has he still got cancer
well we don't know um we don't really
have a way to
to find out really following the release
of nazanin and anushay and he found out
that they'd come back he was meant to be
on furlough and was taken back to the
prison
and on his return to the prison he
decided that he wanted the uk to know
that he was still there and suffering
and and that he
he felt betrayed and abandoned so
he started a hunger strike that went on
nine days but i think it was really
difficult for him even to to give it up
because it was his one sense of
i think control in a way as his child i
imagine you're not sure if he's still
ill
he's not having any treatment then he
goes on a hunger strike i mean you must
be desperately worried about him
we are um but we also we have faith in
him and and his decisions so we wanted
to be supportive but with more days that
passed we thought you know what we
that's why we have to be public now we
can't stay quiet anymore your dad was
put on farley when nazini and nushay
were released which was
meant to be that he was allowed to
return home
and then 48 hours after they landed he
was sent back to prison and he
started a hunger strike which you asked
him to stop
you were led to believe that your dad
would get released as part of that same
deal
why did you believe that and what
happened
the the foreign office is i mean when i
say they the foreign office
told us they assured us that my dad and
mom would be a part of any deal that
they were constructing
for the other two hostages um we
were short at every turn that he wasn't
going to be left behind that he would be
a part of that
and we believe them when did you
discover that your dad wasn't part
of that deal that you've been told he
was part of we found out in the press
when nazineen and anusha were on the
plane
so when it when it went live that they
were coming back
we found out with the rest of the world
through the media
i think the closest
feeling i could describe is probably
betrayal um
we had four years of having faith in the
government and
and they abandoned us and they left him
behind
so you learned about it by reading the
press with everyone else what did you do
then
uh well that's when we had to make a
different decision we'd always been
advised by the foreign office to stay
quiet and out of the media so that
the negotiations wouldn't be negatively
impacted and
and we decided at that juncture maybe we
need to change tact because the other
two families went public
and they got
their family members back that must have
been
i imagine quite personally hard that you
had
put your faith in the foreign office
that you hadn't as
sherry anusha's
wife and obviously richard with nazaneen
that you hadn't
publicly campaigned although you'd
clearly been working very hard to get
your dad's release was that really hard
that you thought
you'd made a
a mistake
yeah uh it was but at the time we
i don't think anyone can be prepared to
be presented with this kind of situation
but we thought it's the foreign office
it's england
surely they know
and you know we weren't in a position to
to go against
their advice because they in theory
would have known better than anyone what
about your mp as well because tulip
sadiq had campaigned very vocally
for nazanin alongside richard what about
your mp
felicity bucknin
my because my home is in notting hill so
i'm i'm kensington and chelsea
i think
it's
it's difficult because
i'm his daughter so he technically
isn't her constituent um
but again everything gets funneled back
to the foreign office anyway
um
so we're
at this point we're just kind of hoping
that liz trust and boris johnson will
really
actually keep up with the promise they
made with to us and and follow through
on the deal that they presented to us
you talked about your dad um
and his citizenship because he has a
triple citizenship he is british
american
and iranian he has three
nationalities
has that been a hindrance do you think
in trying to get him
released
initially we we didn't think it would be
because
we would have thought that having uk us
you'd be in
i mean you'd be fully covered in theory
um
and
now the answer that we're getting from
the foreign office is that his
situation's more complicated because
he's also american and the iranians want
to see him as american
um
it's a bit difficult to stomach because
it's
they can't decide that
you know it
england
knows who their citizens are my dad was
born here he's british
uh they have his birth certificate he
was born in hammersmith hospital he's
he's from here
and
so
so i don't i don't accept that excuse
really anusha said when i spoke to him
and sherry said this his wife as well
that because of the dual citizenship
because they had spent parts of their
lives in iran that when they dealt with
the foreign office sometimes they felt
that people questioned their britishness
and their citizenship is that how you
have felt about your dad as well that
he's not quite british enough for them
to care enough i think it's something
that you always consider
my dad's american citizenship is from
naturalization he he went to university
there and decided to settle down there
with my mom but i don't think that makes
him any less
british nazineen and nushay
they both care very deeply about your
father and about his case anusha
was friends with your dad in heaven
prison he spoke
about how he can't be at peace until
your dad is also released and nazanin
who i think grew close to your mother in
tehran
uh also invited you to her first press
conference to publicize your dad's case
have they been a great source of
strength for you and your family nazanin
spent quite a lot of time actually with
my mom when she was on furlough and they
grew really close
and and richard really forged the way
for us here um it's really
the murky waters to navigate it's it's
challenging because you're carrying this
huge weight with you and everything you
do and say
has an impact in in a different way in
different scenarios
um but it was richard and nazanin that
chose to include us in their celebration
to help us highlight my dad's case
and and they've always been really
encouraging about going public
and they've always invited us to be
included on that um
but because we were trying to follow the
advice we were given we were always very
careful and and stayed away from that
but when they found out that we were
more open to it they were the first ones
to really help us
kind of step out of the shadows and and
into the light and and to help really
your mom is also
now in iraq you're both your parents
you're the eldest of three
siblings and it's kind of fallen on you
to publicize the case you've also got
your own life and your own job i mean it
must be
pretty hard going isn't it
it is
but i guess
you find strength in in quite broken
places and you surround yourself with
people that
that can hold you up when when you don't
feel like you can stand really so i've
been really
lucky i think that's why we're we're
here today and and all the other press
interviews and things we've done it's
been
there is that fear that if we don't stay
public and we don't step forward that
they'll they'll forget him and he'll be
abandoned there for longer than he
already has been your dad is
sentenced to 10 years in prison and he's
what now in his late 60s yes 66
presumably
your feeling is he just
can't be there
for that long you have to get him out we
do and
and i think it's not even just physical
health for anybody in that scenario it's
mental health as well
and they're both there my
my mom's been sat waiting
for ages and if her travel ban was meant
to be lifted the way his furlough was
meant to happen
we still don't understand why she hadn't
been then put on that plane so we could
at least see her for a few days she
would have gone back anyway because
her partner her love of her life is
there
she she wait for him forever they mean
their high school sweethearts you don't
forget somebody like that in your life
what's your message then to liz truss
bring them home
they they promised us and
you know if if nothing else they
they should have upheld the furlough
that they publicly celebrated and
announced because
you know if it if it was decided
then it should happen it's been five
weeks
and nothing's changed there's been no
update of any substantive background of
any sort and
you know we we'd really like some
answers but also i'm really tired of
words
we'd like to see some action now and
just finally do you think the u.s
government
can help get your dad out
i think they they've been working on it
just as hard the state department and
foreign office work in tandem but again
he this is home to him this is who he is
so
and that was who promised us the results
the uk said to us that he was going to
be in the deal
and do you think he do you think you'll
get him back
i can't think about if i don't get him
back because
he he was
i mean he is he it's you can't even say
past tense or present tense anymore
because it's so
complicated but
when it's your dad it's your dad there's
there's no love like the love a daughter
or a son has for a father